we were to have Sheree losing a month
earlier or FINA or an Amontillado what's
the difference with the media there is
not much difference it's just a village
they're very close elegant I have this
softness favor yeah which is this one
what is it possible maybe just try a
little bit yes please
I'm one of the mango one okay yes great
are you
thank you I plead to her rest which is
the sherry couple of Spain gone through
all the classes all the tasting but she
actually managed to explain it very well
in about three sentences and kind of in
wine I don't come here and to be found
with a listeria master classes so nice
think that they look excitement an
amazing insight and very knowledgeable
nice touch
what here's it slapped out and slapped
on the table up to himself in the mirror
didn't look good at the table oh wow
okay so he's in potato
thanks yeah I don't agree with that
thank you I'm trying to give my ways
exams to the wrong table he doesn't have
a clue I wasn't happy might irritate my
god and it's not even my restaurant but
it pains me course we don't want that to
happen
definitely not anyone who comes into
contact with with the customers needs to
know with it no we're talking about
engaged
next Sara's going to play one of the
dirtiest tricks in the secret diners
book putting one of our own hairs in the
food I was so sure so be strong there's
a hair in this salad I just wondered if
I could swap it thank you
really well the waitress has taken it
away she showed it to the manager had a
good look at it they looked at each
other
alcohol and she's taking it it's all
there to make another one thank you
thank you very much thank you
apologetic banks runaway customer at
ease dealt with brilliantly
waitress goes absolutely
that's a shame
what do you make of that Anna who's
looking after the great job but I think
sort of seeing the Junior guide not up
to speed is something that we can do
something about and you know something
that we we ought to improve on
definitely tough tests only human and
when you make mistakes clearly but how
you handle them you know we've got a
couple of things to know to take away a
work on of course we're disappointed it
wasn't 100% perfect but I think most of
the team really do know what they're
doing and you know it's a reasonably
easy job for us to make sure that they
all do that's a good challenge for us
over the next few weeks
our next challenge is gonna be tough we
must send everything perfect so I want
to win nowadays and I we love to win and
I hope we win